alex what do you call a scammer's
favorite card game
go fish
ladies and gentlemen sometimes it's not
enough to just look ahead
sometimes we've got to look back look in
the old rear view
see what's happened to some of these
gurus that we've talked about in the
past that we've taken down
what do they do after they've been
called out by coffeezilla what do they
what do they try to do
well guess what that's me i just
described me right there that's me
yeah i'm 14 years old but that's what
i've done well
let's first take a look at an old friend
of ours now you may know him from our
amazon automation video
and so what we did is we ran a whole
bunch of numbers we run it a hundred
times every way
running the numbers your minimum why not
what numbers hey what numbers
running the numbers your minimum roi is
around 200 percent
minimum i've noticed that these people
after they get called out they start
talking about it
start saying oh don't ignore the haters
ignore the haters and i think it's a
little bit of self-talk to themselves a
little bit sometimes
uh like here we have seth niep from just
one dime
having haters is a sign you're moving
and shaking don't let it get to you uh
some will admire but others will despise
and it will expand to people you have
never met
it's okay then he shows us how how seth
how do you deal with the haters show us
all some people hating on you
hey look i know it can be frustrating
but i do have a solution
here's what you do
[Music]
no dude that's jake paul's strategy you
don't want to do that that's that's like
the dab on the haters thing
and you don't want to do that you really
don't want to do that
it's a losing strategy and besides the
problem is seth
with your strategy is that you actually
are not indifferent
you do care and you care a lot let me
show you guys evidence of this
like check it out if you look up the
video that i exposed
it is gone from youtube he deleted it
off his channel where is it i don't know
he deleted it on top of that i showed
this photoshop problem on one of his
sales pages
where there was this missing gray bar
and i was saying haters will say it's
photoshop
as a joke well guess what seth does he
takes the webpage which i took it from
and he takes it off that's before i
called it out that's after i called out
so he can say all he wants that you
should dab on the haters
but we've gotten to him we've gotten
under his skin
he's like taken down the done for you
automation video
and he's replacing screenshots but we
have a lot of gurus to get to so
that's just a little update there now
let's follow up on kevin saying look
this guy hasn't been doing much
since we last talked about him he really
hasn't been posting much but he did come
back to instagram
to post an embarrassing story
of you know what do you do what am i
doing today having all this money here
but ballerbusters caught him out because
it's fake prop money that he was using
to show off
it says for motion picture use only this
is not
real money that he posted these gurus
i'm telling
you they don't know any other way than
to lie
than to mislead than to try to hide
things from you guys these are the
people you're following again
people who use prop money to brag this
is dude this is so embarrassing
and finally i want to take a look at the
king himself dan lok
right me and dan lok we very kindred
spirits here
and recently i i got him in a little bit
of trouble
when i called him out he wasn't very
happy about it i called him out for this
this right here he took from alex
charfons the billionaire decoded now
what did dan lok do did he double down
did he say stephen you're wrong i didn't
do this to alex jarvin no
but instead the website suddenly changes
overnight this is why you have to
archive these things if you ever see
something suspicious
archive it archive.org you got to save a
snapshot of it because now we have this
saved
but now everything's changed this is the
new dan lok
uh system i don't know if it is familiar
to any you guys it should look a little
bit familiar because it's almost
identical
but he did change it he dumped it down
basically
and now he's got this these new titles
called dragon in the making
now you can be a red dragon when you hit
less than a million
now you could be a black dragon oh
what's that
look at this and he still has the same
kind of ideas here all he's done is
change it just enough to be like
plausibly deniable at this point
and now he's added in valley of death
oh my gosh dude what who does this but
just wait guys because
you the real reason you get the course
the real reason you do this the real
reason you buy in
is for this right here not dragon x
dragon x
is for chumps i would never join if i
was just a dragon x
get ready because you're about to you're
about to find out there's a whole new
level to life that you never knew was
possible
the now my question is is dan lok even
an infinity dragon like
that sounds like it's plagiarized
straight from george rr martin we've
really moved on beyond business advice
dan lok is greater than business advice
you know catch him plagiarizing he'll
just dumb it down and introduce dragons
that's the lesson for today
so guys what do you guys think he's like
let's say you accuse someone of
something
and they don't admit that they did
something wrong but they change
everything you accuse them of
it's like you know you're right so when
these people
are either going and hiding for months
and months and months
or they're having to remove pages from
their website remove screenshots from
their website remove videos
from their channel change entire
business plans
introduce dragons into the mix you know
things are changing guys and hopefully
for the better now i'm under
no illusion that these guys are ever
gonna go away
but hopefully we're moving the needle
that's what it's all about boys
moving the needle for you guys to fall
for these things less
and for this to be less and less doable
i mean we really should all be
mocking these people when this kind of
stuff happens
i hope you enjoyed this little blast
from the past visiting some of our old
gurus let me know if you want me to do
in the future and
as always and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank
[Music]
a you of money why are you